okay so when we do the the uh
sensitivity releasing drill you you're
it's you got to start out with the hands
because it's a more sophisticated skill
that you're doing things with your body
okay uh so now we'll do the same drill
but I know that at full speed there's
going to be a tou he's going to try to
get my Center okay and so uh no matter
how relaxed you are in your hands uh you
have to absorb that in your in your
Center okay which means is the energy is
going down uh and forward then my energy
has to go back and down as well and we
do this all the time in iido so if we
have a uh he has spinal displacement
here and we're doing eal I don't stay
upright and and just move over and try
to do the maneuver okay as as he's press
pressing there's that's where I go back
to his his pressure and I go down to his
pressure and then that's where the
technique happens so very similar here
I'm still going to try to keep as
relaxed in my hands as possible but I'm
going to go ahead and close my fingers
he's going to go ahead and bring his
second hand into the Joe work but not
back to where we started and why we
needed the drill and then to the drill
I'm going to add my ground vectoring and
here is going to add his ground vectory
and we should still be able to do it
don't go fast just working on the
relaxation
sorry come
on
you need more
[Applause]
tou
[Music]
more
for
okay let's
go
all right move number seven
okay
um so we'll we'll just get there s it up
I come
in I come
in it's right here okay so here here he
was and just like before have your
better base there you go just like
before I have a cross how do I have that
cross I will continue the iy
adhesion under
fear I would tense up and if I tensed up
at full speed I will try to maintain
yangong at a mechanical disadvantage
what would happen is I'll get my foot
pinned on the atos on his atos and my
weapon will go flying off creating the
angle of deflection that he wanted and
now he would cut my hand off
okay but what my counter is because the
set requires me to counter is not for
him to half acid and not for me to not
engage in my thrust but to stay and
maintain the IE adhesion in essence I'm
going to do a counter rotation of the
cross that he rotated so when he goes on
his atos I keep the adhesion on the
inside and as he starts to come in to
cut my hand I rotate
that okay I won't go all the way over
like on the first Joe rotation because
the hands I will attack from the
homolateral side and this is where I'll
I'll smack that down
okay so first let me just show you the
the hand attack because that is the
strategy of the Joe the strategy of the
bul in here in this set is to defang the
snake the strategy of the Joe is today
called a stop hit where I don't let his
attack manifest I attack it at its
source in this case the hands okay so as
we go around one slow down so I can talk
please and when I come around here I'm
hitting those hands over to attack that
weapon okay he keeps the adhesion you
you have too much tension your sword I
would not come
in Taylor first off you tell me your
mistake I wasn't doing the two-part
adhesion yeah and what would happen when
I go
fast U my part wouldn't matter I'd get
checked off yeah okay so you by you
holding your sword in the rotating cross
instead of going with it you held your
position in the rotating cross got it
you would be checked out do you
understand and I'm going to still ski
you your sword might even go flying out
of your hands okay so show me what you
did
wrong you're going to talk me I'm going
to do my move but I'm going to go slow
so you can
talk as we got to about here I hel it
yes you didn't you didn't write it over
you let it go over yes then it comes
back got
it so we'll try it again okay looking at
the Joe's strategy is to attack the
hands so I go up boom and here's where I
attack the hands to create my angle of
deflection there's my angle of attack
now and now I'm going to do it again as
he comes
back boom I'm going to attack the hands
there in
makios again why does the Joe do this
well this has an advantage in it's
trying to defang the snake if I never
let it get out of the gate it's not
going to defang the snake also my
follow-up attack is a ski and I don't
want him running away from the ski for
me to have a viable ski I have to have
resistance to the weapon so he if I
plant him and have downward energy his
MK plus that inertia is now going to add
resistance to the ski generating
opposing forces at impact making it more
damaging so I have to try to pin him
okay so we go again one two
3 four back in boom is there the and
then
this off the wall
[Applause]
please
[Music]
is
for
all right let's try detail
on okay
uh
it comes straight down the weapon
straight down the
weapon two hands hit the
atos okay and then you spin
it careful you're you're not moving it
that way
okay so that's the first it does doesn't
move laterally it comes straight down to
your toch straight down the book in so
follows that complimentary
angle right there is where it hits okay
and it hits with two hands the second
common mistake rewind a little is that
people hit with one
hand on the spin no it hits with two
hands and then the third common mistake
is a hit and then spin it it's not it I
hit with two hands and immediately it
transitions into the spin to give me
that little extra bit of deflection and
a tushi okay so his weapon is would be
out here okay it's not I don't go like
this first mistake
laterally second mistake I'm turning it
with one I'm hitting with one hand cuz
I'm going to turn it third mistake I hit
and then turn it after the five the
movement is going to
go so I hit with two hands and
immediately a contact boom it turns okay
to give me that extra little bit I'll do
it again the three major
mistakes
lateral no correction straight down
second mistake one hand a tush cuz
you're turning it no two hands hit boom
is where you do it third mistake is two
hands hit and then this is after the
fact no it goes together and around okay
let's try it
again